hey everyone uh welcome to a frequently
requested
puzzle solving video now i've done quite
a few videos already on exercises i just
had a four video series where i solved
exercises of various difficulties
and a couple of months back i also did a
uh three-part
video on puzzle rush but what i wanted
to do for this video is just do it all
in one video i want to go from zero to
50 in puzzle rush survival
and i want to do it all at once
and there are two reasons behind it
first of all
i think the puzzle solving videos have
turned out really well people like them
so i want to make more of them
and uh well i guess three reasons the
second is that uh more puzzles equals uh
better
and uh the third reason is that i really
want to show everybody what that
progression of difficulty looks like
and uh this will allow me to share
advice uh on various
uh puzzle solving levels and as the
puzzles get more difficult i will do my
best to talk about sort of what uh what
new skills are required to solve uh to
solve the problems as they get harder
now for those of you watching on youtube
i am also streaming this on twitch so uh
my twitch viewers are getting early
access to this video and i will be
referring to my chat occasionally but i
won't be doing it often
okay
without further ado let us begin
oh this is funny i
uh this is from a previous a previous
puzzle solving session so let me get
three of them wrong let's see how we can
blunder our queen in the best possible
way and
let me make sure not to get it right by
accident
my chat my chat is laughing right now
rook a2 all right this is how
grandmaster does puzzle rush here we go
now the slate is wiped clean
and we can begin now the first first 10
problems
are generally extremely simple
almost all of them involve a very
straightforward
tactical concept that is
easy to see and then easy to follow up
on so for example here
we notice that the rooks are doubled we
see that white's king
is stuck behind the pawns this is a
classic background checkmate right and
what's also assisting us in these
puzzles is that generally in in many
cases
we're going to be down a ton of material
so you kind of know that you have to
deliver checkmate
and you just start by looking at the
checks
and
most of the time you're going to see the
mate really quickly even if you're
pretty new to chess rook c1 rook takes
you one is checkmate
all right same deal here
there's a little bit more going on
currently white is up a piece
but the problem is that if you just move
the knight back then the bishop on d7 is
going to hang black is going to
recapture it
and you you must not forget that
checkmates are very possible even with
queens off the board this is
particularly a piece of advice to
beginners you should not switch off your
checkmate detector just because you're
in an endgame or or the king is in the
center
and uh and so we should immediately
start by looking at checks all right we
have a fork on c6 but there's a pawn on
b7 guarding that square but if you look
at this bishop on d2 you can slide on up
to b4 and that is just checkmate bishop
before his mate because the bishop is
defended the knight also guards f7 the
bishop guards e8 and the king cannot
step onto any of its pieces so bishop b4
is easy
all right so the next one is another
background checkmate same pattern here
we see that the king behind the pawns
and we have an open file so we can just
take white's rook and then take all of
white's pieces on on the first ring so
i'm going to go through these puzzles
very very quickly often times you'll
have the same theme repeated in four or
five puzzles again a back rank mate we
have a rook on the open file
don't pay attention to this as the
puzzles get slightly more difficult
uh there's a little bit more fluff
that's added there's distracting factors
uh that that you have to
you know filter or understand which ones
to filter but here it's literally just
back rank mate for like six puzzles in a
row rook b1 rook takes c1
and rook takes e1
okay so this one's another maiden one
there is a back rank weakness but that's
not the theme
clearly we should notice this battery we
have a bishop and a queen on the same
diagonal that is called a battery
and uh batteries generally aim at a
particular pawn
or a particular piece so we just need to
look at where this is aiming well it's
aiming on b2 easy easy checkmate
all right this is a tiny bit harder but
not by much yet again we have to notice
the queen and the rook this is also a
battery
uh this battery is trained at f7 so we
should take that pawn and now a very
simple back rank made combination we
just have we just have to go queen f8
technically a queen sacrifice but a very
simple one and once again back rank man
on f8
okay
so um
hopefully hopefully not all 50 puzzles
will be on the theme of background
checkmate okay so for this one black is
up two rooks for a bishop but
just looking at this position you can
see that the queen is hitting the rook
on f8 in between these two rooks you
should obviously take the one with check
and then we can start thinking in
earnest
so the only tempting thing that i see
here is to come come back and take the
other rook
but that can be ruled out because
white's king is tremendously weak black
has all these checks
it's not worth it that's you know these
puzzles are not going to result in a
messy solution so instead you should
continue looking at uh ways that you can
coordinate the bishop and the queen with
a with a check there's bishop g8 check
but then the king escapes to h6 but it's
much better to lead with a queen in
these kinds of situations queen g8 check
forces the king to h6 and then queen h8
is just checkmate so as long as you look
over all of the checks uh you're going
to find them made there's no there's no
special formula or secret here just got
to be methodical
okay
so first thing i see is that white's
king is really out in the open so let's
look around to see if there are any
tactical ideas i also noticed that the
knight on e3 is loose
okay so i'm seeing that the queen and
the king are lined up
and i've really drilled that in in
previous puzzle solving videos this is
something you always have to watch for
the x-ray because the x-ray creates the
possibility for a move like night before
check the pawn on c3 is going to be
pinned
and uh we're going to win white's queen
check it takes d3
so two things there the first is you
look for x-rays the second is you look
for sort of a forkable situation anytime
your opponent's king and rook or your
opponent's king and queen are a night's
distance apart are forkable by a knight
even if there is no knight in the
vicinity you should kind of make a
mental note to yourself about that and
i'm sure we're gonna have a puzzle where
you know the knight essentially has to
get to the right square and then give a
fork here again it's just a fork in one
move rook king knights uh knight can
fork on e7 and to add insult to injury
when we take black's rook
uh black can't even take with a pawn
because the rook on f8 is gonna hang so
boom
boom all right first 10 were easy
okay so once again black's king kind of
surrounded by white's pieces here this
is almost the same puzzle that we had a
couple puzzles ago with a check on d7
forcing the king to b8 and then a
backrank mate pattern here on d8 so
again very easy
all right so apart from x-rays you also
have to
always see alignment of your opponent's
king and queen or queen and rook when
they're all on the same diagonal
that's when you should start looking for
a pin so immediately i see that the king
and the queen are on the same diagonal
do we have a dark square bishop we do
can it pin the king to the queen it can
bishop c5 that square is defended we win
the queen
all right
so
again
both kings here are
under some fire black is threatening
checkmate which tells me that we
basically have to play with checks
there's only one feasible check i mean
guess there's queen a8 but queen e8
keeps the the queen in closer proximity
to the king so let's start with this
check
ah and now this rook on g3 aiming at the
g7 pawn should give you the right clue
you drop the queen back to g6 and then
take on g7
as long as you practice uh if you're new
to chess
you know all you need to do with these
kinds of puzzles just practice a million
of them and your pattern recognition for
these easy sequences is going to come
really fast so here we have an end game
clearly it's not going to be a
checkmating
a checkmating routine
but instead i'm noticing that we have
two pawns here and black only has one
and black strokes are nowhere to be
found
so all we really have to do is create a
pass pawn which is going to be
unstoppable it's also important that the
g2 pawn is protected by the rook boom
boom boom and black will have to
give away a rook for the pawn
all right so here black is up in
exchange
and um one thing that begins to be added
right around puzzle 15 puzzle 20 is the
notion of undefended pieces you start
getting a lot of exercises where you
have to kind of spot lose pieces and
then exploit their weakness so i'm
seeing this bishop on d3 in a previous
video i talked about type 1 and type 2
on defended pieces basically a type 2
undefended piece is a piece that is only
protected by one other piece and the
point is that it remains very loose that
bishop on d3 can be forked with guinea
poor check and then we take the bishop
boom
obviously not with a rook because the
queen is hanging
take stakes
okay same exact theme here i immediately
see the alignment of white's queen with
a bishop on e7 so this is an overloading
tactic the queen on d8 has to protect
two pieces at once we take the rook and
we take the bishop
all right so here we
okay well we have to take black's queen
to start there's no other move
and now we have to refrain from king
takes g3 as you can see black will take
the pawn
this pawn however is totally unstoppable
we can just push it
all right
so this is oh this is a nice mating
pattern the first thing you should see
here after filtering out all of the
fluff on the queen side is the open h
file an open file like this is almost
always going to be a precursor to mate
so one thing you might see here is this
idea of rook h8 check distracting
forcing the king to h8 then queen h3
check king g8 queen h7 checkmate
unfortunately that doesn't work and
one thing you always have to check for
no pun intended after you've given a
check is whether your opponent can block
that check it's just a mental note that
you have to make to yourself and do that
every time after rook h8 king takes he
queen h3 black has bishop h4
and um
and all of a sudden white's attack dries
up so rather than going rook h8 we have
to embark on a different sequence which
starts with bishop h7
this forces the king
on to h8 this time we have a discovery
now where should we go with the bishop
if you aren't familiar with this pattern
it can be kind of tricky because
you might be thinking all right well
let's drop back to g6 or back to f5 but
that doesn't make any progress what you
have to realize here is that
essentially you have to do a little
switcheroo you have to find a way to
clear the pathway for a white's queen
the problem with keeping the bishop on
this diagonal is that the queen is
unable
to make its way to h7
and so once you have that in mind you
should see the move bishop g8
forcing i mean the point of that move is
just to get rid of the bishop so that
the queen has access to h7 boom
boom
all right
well this is just a case of a hanging
piece i think this knight on c4 can just
be captured by the bishop so really
elementary stuff there and now you don't
want to take with the queen and allow a
queen trade you want to take with a
bishop when the king is checkmated so
black will have to give up a full queen
easy enough
okay so seems like material is equal
here
now not only do you have to notice open
files you have to notice semi-open files
when it comes to your opponent's king a
semi-open file is a file that only
contains your opponent's pawns on it
which means that it doesn't have your
pawns on it so for all intents and
purposes from your perspective it's
basically an open file so
with white's last move the h7 pawn was
captured opening up that file i also see
that the queen is aiming at the pawn on
h2 if you combine that you should see
the move rook h8 creating a
an unstoppable skewer white will have to
give the queen up
okay bishop f4 is a nice move
um
and the point is that if queen takes f4
you lose you lose sight of the rook
but uh you what you have to not be
afraid of here is essentially
transforming your advantage right you
can't give checkmate anymore so what you
have to realize is that you just gotta
go for the extra piece just take the
queen
white takes the queen and knight takes
e5 and that's going to be a common
ending to
some of these exercises maybe your eye
was caught by the desperado queen takes
c3
but
then white has
sudden checkmate on c7 so be very
careful in these situations all right 20
down 30 to go
um
all right
well this is i think very
straightforward again
white is down to queen so we kind of
have to play with checks first move has
to be rook takes b7
and the bishop defends the rook in the
second move we have an open c file just
get the c1
and which piece do we take with well we
take with the bishop we want to preserve
the rook as the checkmating piece boom
and it's me
all right so this is kind of a an
arabian mate theme
first thing i'm seeing is the presence
of a rook and a knight the rook and the
knight can combine in many cases
to deliver a what's called an arabian
maiden if you're not familiar with the
term just take a moment pause the video
and google it
but you're about to see a version of it
now i see two checks we can start with
the rook a8 we can start with knight f6
don't get overwhelmed by two different
move orders just
try to logically examine each of them
and you know and see which one works
so
knight f6 check allows the king to go up
to g7
and at best we can repeat with knight h5
but the king escapes the checks on g6
and what's the difference let's see rook
a check king h7
okay let's say we go knight f6 check now
that's the only check ah and after king
g6 you'll notice that the rook now has
access to the g8 square and that is
checkmate that's the difference check
first now knight f6 and rook g8 and that
king on e5 was doing a very important
job protecting the knight
all right
so
once again as i mentioned for puzzles 20
to 30 a lot of them are going to be on
the theme of undefended pieces and
double attacks rook on a7 is unprotected
you've got an unprotected piece and a
weak king in close proximity to each
other so queen c5 is a pretty much a
no-brainer take that rook
rook to queen takes g2 and this rook is
hanging all we have to do is move it not
to g1 but to f1 where it's protected
okay
so this one
black is down two rooks in a piece
so once again
it tells you that this has to be some
sort of checkmating sequence but
can we give a check on g4 well no we
can't because that square's defended
so we just don't have a lot of these
puzzles
you can use process of elimination you
just don't have that many resources at
your disposal
um
and you will not be able to mate only
with the queen so you have to go knight
f4
uh threatening made on g2 and amazingly
it turns out that
white does not have any effective checks
knight g6 check is an attempt to
distract the knight which we're not
going to fall for we're going to take
with the pawn
okay and we're going to take the queen
and we're going to win
okay so for this one i'm noticing two
things the king is on e1
and there is no pawn on f2 anytime that
happens
automatically you've got to think about
queen h4 in this case it's just mate
boom boom and this is basically a
scholars mate all right halfway there
now the problems begin to get a little
bit more tricky but still pretty simple
all right so this is a case of
essentially two past pawns trying to
overwhelm a single rook
um
so the way to think about these kinds of
exercises is that
um
is that the rook itself is not going to
be able to contain
the king and the two past pawns so a
common mistake here would be to go rook
h2 right maybe you've heard the
principal rook behind past pawns
but that's not going to cut it because
white's just going to push g5 and then
push h7
and black's king is too far away
so you have to find an alternate
alternate approach to the position
and one thing you might notice is that
rook takes f3 as possible the pawn
hasn't promoted yet
rook takes f3 h7
and now very typical end game idea you
parked the rook on h3
and you basically say i'm going to give
this rook up for the pawn
so i'm going to force white to burn two
more moves and in the meantime i'm going
to start pushing my e pawn
and in the time that it takes for white
to force
uh to force black to give up the rook
this pawn is gonna basically already
promote so rook takes f3
okay g5
um now you don't want to make any moves
that are not strictly necessary right so
rook
h3 would be a mistake here there's no
rush with this move in fact i think
after rook h3 king f5 white is able to
draw so you want to play e4 and only
when absolutely necessary do you want to
stop the pawn ooh they got danny wrench
in the chat subbin for eight months
thank you danny uh and here rook f8
would allow king g7 with tempo
understand the subtleties and rooks of
course belong behind past pawns this is
a pure application of the rule one last
thing
i see this a lot with beginner players
the move rook takes h7
is uh is very common because there is a
tendency to to get scared when your
opponent is about to promote what you
have to understand is that white's newly
minted queen is not going to last long
it's going to be captured by the rook
and you're wasting a move by taking that
pawn preemptively in fact that gives
white enough time to promote his own
pawn instead you push and only now do
you take the pawn and you've gained a
tempo this is a winning end game
hopefully that made sense
all right
so
i'm gonna let my chat solve this one
all right guys tell me the best move and
of course for those watching on youtube
i'll still explain the solution
but uh
you know i gotta reward my twitch peeps
for uh for sticking with me while i'm
recording this video
yeah so everybody getting it
and for most of you guys for most of the
people in the chat i think this is still
in the realm of pattern recognition
um
all you really have to do here you have
a queen and a bishop you have a wide
open king you just need to go
methodically through all of the checks
and see which ones work
queen d8 check comes to mind but then
king f7 and the king escapes via g6
well maybe we should take the bishop
now why is it a bad idea to take the
bishop what is black going to do in that
case
obviously i know that there is made but
who can tell me what happens if you take
the bishop
well black doesn't promote immediately
there's a queen on a1 but that's
basically right black is going to move
the queen away and who knows what's
going to happen it's very hard to stop
that pawn once it's on a2 and the
promotion square is defended so
forget about the bishop let's keep
looking for mate if you look hard enough
you'll see bishop d6 check this forces
the king to e8
and now very typical checkmating pattern
slide the queen in queen e7 queen c7
this exists in many different types of
positions
all right so next position we've got
okay so we've got it rooks doubled on
the g file
first move seems pretty obvious it's got
to be rook takes you to now the fun
begins
an important observation white is
threatening basically the same thing
with queen d7 so that kind of tells me
that we have to play with check
and so the move rook g1 comes to mind
common mistake but if you look a little
bit further you will see that white gets
way too much stuff for the queen i
mentioned this in two videos ago when
you're winning your opponent's queen
make sure that you are actually counting
the material that your opponent is
getting in return so if not rook g1
well rook takes h2 is the only other
check and it works we force the king to
h2 and the queen slides into f2
with mate
all right
moving right along so here our queen is
hanging
we're up a piece with white but our our
king on e1 is really really weak so i
feel like white needs to also play very
actively here the move queen b5 is
definitely possible but
it's not particularly impressive black
also has a bunch of pawns for the piece
and black can even go queen d7 and
remember that the
the win condition for most of these
exercises is going to be more than you
know being a pawn up or being a point up
in material so the move bishop b5 can be
considered and i think it should be
played
after c6 we have a little bit of a
challenge
a little bit of a challenge
now i'll relegate this back to my chat
this pawn can be captured in two
different ways both moves are very
tempting we can play dc and try to sack
the queen but get a discovery or we can
play bishop takes c6 i want to see how
many people get the right capture
yeah everybody's getting it the move is
bishop takes c6 you do not want to play
dc
because after black takes the queen
we push that pawn to c7 and we say ah we
win black screen back but black's queen
is not going to give itself up for
nothing it's going to slide up to d7 in
that position
the problem is we're going to have to
capture with our bishop the king takes
and black is winning there black has won
back the the piece that was lost
and white's position is in shambles so
we take with the bishop
and now we take with the queen and we
force black's king out into the open
where we're going to finish it off windy
7 is less resilient because the rook
hangs on a8
all right
end game
well it's a rook and bishop versus rook
end game which normally is a draw so
with best play in any given rook and
bishop versus rook position
the side of the rook should be able to
save the game but the exceptions
involve the king being on the side of
the board because he can get checkmated
and the obvious move here is king f4
this creates essentially the unstoppable
threat of brook h8 the only subtlety is
here right we don't want to move our
king again we want to block this check
with our bishop
which uh builds
just a decisive cage for black's king
okay f3 king f3 that was easy and 20
more
all right so
once again undefended pieces always
something that should be in the back of
your mind this bishop on d6
is under a lot of pressure and it's
defended by the queen and as i like to
mention the queen is the worst defender
because it's so easy to attack and when
the queen is attacked it kind of has to
respond to that and so the move knight
b5 comes to mind almost immediately boom
bishop takes f3 now don't be overwhelmed
by
a lot of stuff going on just work it out
calculationally like if you take the
queen then black takes the queen and
remember that right now black is up a
piece
so
at best material is going to be equal
but if you just take on f3 with a queen
nothing has changed you still have the
fork that's much simpler and much
stronger and okay we take the queen and
we win
oh this is a nice pattern
so
the king is out of squares and that's
kind of a special situation whenever the
king literally has no escape squares
your checkmate alarm bell should be
ringing very loudly so
what you can notice here is that if the
b file is open
rook b8 would have been checkmate and so
maybe queen takes a6 comes to mind but
that's not a check
black can respond with a rook takes rook
check and distract white strip from b1
instead you can do that with a check
boom
very nice pattern there
all right this is a very easy one rook
on e8 type 2 on defended piece it's only
protected by the queen and the king is
also very exposed so queen f7 should be
kind of automatic here right boom
just don't take with a rook because
you're going to get checkmated we want
to take with the queen here
and we stop the pawn there ah this is a
nice pattern so
this is a really good one
uh i want my chat to tell me not only
the solution but the type of mate that
this is what is this mate called and the
way that it's defined is
again we have a situation where white's
king is out of squares
and this bishop on f5 is covering two of
its most important escape squares this
is called bowden's mate named after
samuel bowden i believe a 19th century
player
uh it's not that he invented it i think
it's commonly the consensus is that he
was maybe the first to
uh to play this mate in a recorded game
and and the point is that
the the knight is not necessary for the
mating sequence because the bishop is
already doing its job
so what we do is we play knight takes a2
check
and the key insight is that if this pawn
on b2 is gone the bishop comes out to a3
with checkmate there's many different
instantiations of bowden's mate this is
just one way to get it and the way to do
that is rook takes c3 forcing the pawn
out of there and the bishop a3 was made
another pattern that you should just
file away into your mental rolodex of
of mating sequences and you know
eventually you'll start noticing these
kinds of things quickly
all right so
what i'm noticing here is that white's
king seems very exposed the f-file is
open
and white's queen is completely out of
the game in addition black's king is
safe from checks which tells me that the
move does not have to be a check
and the move that really jumps out at me
is just queen g3
that just seems to create completely
devastating threats against white's king
let's just go for it i feel like too
much calculation is unnecessary here and
now now as i mentioned previously i
think it's another case of transforming
the advantage right you were going queen
g3 because you wanted to mate your
opponent but now you have to be flexible
and realize that we use the weakness of
white's king in order to win a bunch of
material all we have to do is rook takes
f1 and then queen takes d3 and that is
totally devastating the bishop is going
to get forked on the next move
all right
so next position
all right so we've got two
monster nights this is you know sort of
the first thing that i'm noticing
and i can bet you that the tactic is
going to involve one if not both of them
who sees the solution this is actually
not that simple
the first thing that i saw was the idea
of knight f takes e7 and malcolm in my
chat is offering that 97 97 and then
knight f6
all right we forked the rook and the
queen of the rook
but don't forget about the knight on g4
which guards that square so that that's
just a trade
but after knight takes e7 knight takes
e7 we have an alignment situation the
queen and the knight are aligned and as
i said you have to spot all open files
and so the move here that totally
devastates black is a rook f7 that's
gonna win a piece boom
we just gotta find one more way to put
pressure on the knight and that would be
bishop h4 right and this is a pretty
straightforward move and then black
doesn't have any more defenders
and these pins against the queen are the
worst and it's over
okay
so
this
seems to be one where white's king is
really really weak black's got a bunch
of pieces surrounding it
the moment i say that next thing i look
for semi-open files and open files
there's one semi-open file and the rook
is on it so rook takes g2 comes to mind
immediately and that also threatens mate
on f2 that's got to be devastating so
like if white takes the bishop then
there's main on f2 and this knight is
pinned so i feel like white just cannot
untangle there boom
okay queen f2 queen take c2 it's just me
exposition
oh oh this one's really cool
so clearly it's going to be one on the
topic of checkmate
and the move queen a8 check comes to
mind immediately
but if you calculate you'll see that
after king d7 there's no further checks
so you got to think a little bit outside
the box here got to notice the x-ray
black's king
can step aside and that's going to be a
checkmate immediately king h7 check
okay let's just be very cautious here
don't take with the queen
because the rook x-ray defends the
bishop instead of course we want to take
with the rook i believe
take with a rook
and now another case of transforming
your attack into a material advantage
don't look for something that's not
there rook d7 doesn't work queen c5
doesn't work we just take the rook
and that's it
all right so king wide open white is
down to rooks let's start looking for
checks
mental note to self let's not allow the
king back to c7 when you're hunting for
the king
and you feel a little bit overwhelmed
in addition to just brute force kind of
just looking at all the moves you can
also make metal notes notes to yourself
about where you don't want to allow the
king to escape so for example if we take
on d4 the king escapes back to c7 and
that seems to be backward progress that
essentially only leaves queen d6 check
and now
those of you who are seasoned that
pattern recognition you should find the
mate queen b4
king a6 bishop c4 but it's not too late
to be sloppy queen c5 check remember
from one of the very first exercises i
mentioned that when you're almost mating
do not forget to check or whether your
opponent can block the check that's a
very common cause of mistakes at this
stage of the game queen b4 is better
boom mate okay
so
lots going on here we've got
a pin against the queen we've got a
pretty weak king on g1 but it doesn't
seem like there's anything in particular
what else can i observe okay so i see
the undefended bishop on d4
that seems like a big deal if we capture
it it's going to be check
and i see a type 2 undefended piece on
b6 so this construction
is catching my eye for some reason even
though the knight is attacking the rook
who sees the solution
yeah so bishop a7 is the move
and hopefully you saw that as well after
knight takes rook we take the bishop on
d4 and then at the very least we can
take the knight on a8 black is going to
have two pieces for the rook and a
completely devastating attack with this
many pieces in the center bishop a7
creates unstoppable threats against the
knight okay queen d1 and just take take
all right 10 more
i think we're doing doing well this is
going to be obviously a slightly longer
video but hopefully not too overwhelming
so far these of course are the toughest
ten this is where things get more
calculationally heavy and you know where
you often have to do
three four or five moves ahead okay so
clearly we have these this assembly of
white pieces we've got the knight on the
queen this is leading me to believe that
queen h7 basically has to be the correct
move but let's find a follow-up queen h7
king f8 when you're trying to get a
sense of these positions start by
looking at the most obvious line because
if that line works you save yourself a
lot of trouble queen h7 king f8 queen h8
king e7
and then we've got the move rook takes
e6 check
okay
then
okay black has to take on e6 and if
you're visualizing that position
it's a situation where both queens are
hanging the white the black queen is
hanging and the white queen is hanging
the first thing you look for in such
situations is whether you can move your
queen away with check and then take your
opponent's queen and you can if you look
carefully you will see that you have
queen takes pawn check or sing the king
out and then we take black's queen
believe it or not black has a lot of
pieces for the queen but we also have
like six extra pawns here so i think
that's it
let's go boom
boom boom okay king d7 is another
defense
but here i think the simplest is
probably just to take black's queen and
after rook takes h8 just to take the
bishop and we've got three extra pawns
which is more than enough
even by puzzle puzzle battle stamp
puzzle rush standards so boom
and it's over
okay
so
first thing i see here is the pawn on a2
being very close to promotion
this is telling me that the tactic you
know the solution has to be related to
that but maybe not as directly as we
think what else can i notice i also see
white's king i also see why it's king
and i notice that if we can push it to
h1 we do have a rook on f8 that can
slide on over to f1
right now i'm brainstorming i don't know
exactly how this connects yet so
really without
go and white is also threatening a check
on a8 so let's start by looking at
bishop takes bishop
let's start by looking at bishop takes
bishop remember the rule checks captures
threats
and that rule is a very good guideline
even for these more complicated problems
after bishop takes pawn takes
if you've done a diligent job of the
observations you will notice that this
gives the rook on f8 an open file cuts
off the king and 92 check leads to
backrank main so bishop takes d takes is
forced
okay so after bishop takes c5 d takes e5
who can tell me
what black should do there
who can tell me what black should do
there
yeah so i think the solution is just
rook takes f4
which does two things it threatens
knight e2 and rook f1 and the second
thing that it does is
and
you know pat yourself on the back if you
saw that the rook wants to swing to a4
and knock out the rook from a3
okay so this is a classic example of
combining two sets of observations one
about white's king the other about the
pawn on a2 it's also about realizing
that the rook can never leave a3 so the
knight isn't actually hanging
takes
takes okay rook takes a2 is
is is easy just knight takes a two and
we're up a rock
okay
okay
so
first thing i see black's king
surrounded by the knights
i'm seeing some smothered made action i
mean if we can get this knight to f7
maybe not smothered mate but it seems to
be pretty devastating
so how can we go about that
well we can do that in a couple of
different ways we can go knight g5
we can go knight g5
we can also go knight takes d6
so i want to see what my chat thinks
which of those do you guys prefer or
neither
is there a third move
yeah so most most of my chat seems to
lean toward knight g5
but i would say that the issue with that
after knight g5 black plays h6
which is a common defense to
to this kind of thing and after knight
f7 check the king has h7 i'm not
entirely convinced
by that position to be to be totally
honest
so
let's have a look at knight takes d6
okay so knight takes d6 threatens knight
f7
um and
probably after knight takes d6 black has
to make some luft with h6
but i would say the difference there is
that knight f7 check at the very least
wins the bishop on d7 at the very least
um
if not more than that so between these
two moves i think knight takes d6 just
looks a lot more devastating
i'll put it this way i'm not 100 sure
that knight takes d6 is the move
but once you get to the 40s sometimes
you just have to trust your intuition it
just looks like all of these threats and
all of these pieces have to amount to
something
they have to amount to something
but
i'll put it this way i may be only
80 to 90 sure that it's knight takes d6
the rook is also hanging yeah that's
something which is
uh which i missed believe it or not i
just didn't notice that the rook was
hanging that's a good thing to notice
now does that matter is the question
well let's think knight takes d6 bishop
takes e1
knight takes d6 bishop takes c1
then we go
knight f7 check king g8
okay
and then we need some sort of
quiet move i guess
yeah i wasn't even looking at a poor
rook exactly no knight d6 bishop e1
is not
not entirely clear-cut believe it or not
and maybe knight f7 check king g8 and
then just move this knight away to g5
and it's entirely possible that white's
attack is devastating but maybe it isn't
so
this is uh this is not any not an easy
exercise at all
i would say
we should probably risk it and i
mentioned this in the previous puzzle
solving video i'm just as human as you
are
you know and and i can get impatient too
but i think it's worth the risk let's go
knight takes d6
it's incorrect
wow maybe it was knight g5
maybe it was knight g5 we'll have to
take a look at it after we get to 50.
wow
very very difficult exercise
all right um we'll just have to analyze
it afterwards
i guess bishop takes c1
i guess bishop takes c1 was was not not
clear-cut
okay so this one we have to start by
taking white's queen
we have to start by taking white's queen
and this seems very easy i think we just
have to push our pawns and i mentioned
this earlier the pawns often overwhelm
the rook g3
rook c3
okay we just have to avoid h2 because
then the rook takes the pawn with check
so we just have to go g2
and we have to find the right square for
the king
if we go king h6 or we go to the h file
the rook takes the pawn with check
if we go to f8 my worry is that the b
pawn is going to promote with check
which really only leaves f6
all right um
okay so again it's going to be one of
those
potential mating nets
let's see the first move well i'm
noticing that there is a
there is an x-ray against the king so
knight takes f5 comes to mind but after
king h5 i'm not convinced and black is
also threatening queen f3
so do we have any other checks so we
have rook takes g6
and then after pawn takes g6 we have
queen h8 that's it
the rook has to cover on h7
and then it's a type 2 undefended piece
the king is the defender and we just go
knight f7 check forcing the king forward
and then that's mate that's a pretty
simple sequence
okay let me take stage six all right
so
for this one i'm noticing a few things
i'm i'm seeing that there is an x-ray
down the e-file
i'm seeing that there's an x-ray down
the e-file but i don't really see a way
to exploit it
and then i'm also seeing that this queen
on f6 that there is a pattern
where you basically trap that queen with
a bishop g5 but it's not you can't go
that immediately because at the very
least black can take on f3 so the
question immediately becomes can we get
rid of this pin first well we can we can
go g4 right
and after bishop g6 we go bishop g5 the
queen is trapped
so i think g4 is a very safe bet
yes very good next one
okay
so
this is clearly going to be one where we
have to evade the checks now first thing
i can rule out is f takes g3
um because after queen takes g3
forget the checks the
rook on d6 is hanging and the queen's
gonna capture it
the queen's gonna capture it and white's
attack fizzles out so it's gonna be a
king move and the point is gonna be to
evade the checks as quickly as possible
because white's got a crushing attack
against black's king
where can we go to evade the checks in
the most robust way possible
okay so king f1 comes to mind
as one possibility
and king h2 as another and king h1 all
three moves are possible but this is
going to be another toughie
um
now let's think
king h2
there is another check on h3 and then we
go king g2
and i don't really see any subsequent
checks there
but king f1 also covers against the
checks immediately
king f1 there might be queen f3 though
there might be this incredibly tricky
defensive resource queen f3
but then we just take on d7 black has no
subsequent checks
i think yeah well king f1 my chat is
asking about queen c4 check but then all
you have to do is take on c4
take on d7 and the rook's gonna hang on
g3
so after king f1 the rook on g3 is
hanging
and a queen trade would be in white's
favor i think king f1 is
is is the most clear-cut move because it
the king is relatively speaking is as
safe as it gets on f1
um of course my confidence is a little
bit
a little bit shot after that
previous problem but
nonetheless i think i think it has to be
king f1
but still i mean what's bothering me
here is i can't really understand why
king h2
is is wrong king h2 rook h3 king g2
um pretty tough batch today
i gotta say um
rook g3 maybe there's some something
crazy
uh but i think we should go for king f1
i think we should go for king f1
i just don't see a defense for black
after king f1
yep okay queen takes c1 check
now this is a small trap if we play king
takes e1 the rook slides down to g1 and
then black picks up the rook on d6
so we just got to be a little bit
careful here and we have to take with
the queen in order not to allow the
check at this level you get a ton of
these subtleties so you just got to be
very vigilant takes takes
all right
and this one i feel like will be a
little bit easier because kind of it's
clear that all we have to do is
extricate the knight
um if we can get this knight off of out
of a2 and escape we're going to be a
piece up so that is our objective let's
calculate well the obvious move is
knight takes c3 right what is white
going to do white's going to go rook c1
what if we defend with a rook c5
well it seems that in that in that
position white's only serious move is
king up to b4
now i'm going to ask my chat
what does black have in that position
and something i mentioned many puzzles
ago it comes into play
in that critical position that's knight
a2 check and then we pick up the rook we
have a rook trade and blacks up a piece
so again night in close proximity to the
king and the rook
and you've got to start looking for
forks takes
here by the way if white had gone king
b3 then still knight a4 is good or even
knight takes c4
okay that was easy enough
and um just a few more
all right so it's an opening
it's an opening where the first thing
that jumps out at me is that white has a
lead in development and that's sort of
the first thing i see
and
one pattern that that i'm noticing is if
we just play knight e5 here it's a
simple move but it creates a massive
threat of bishop c4 which would pile on
the pressure on f7
and again you can cheat a little bit in
these positions because clearly there
are no tactics there's nothing else to
do
so
even though i haven't fully calculated
95 i know it's going to be a very
powerful move
all right danny see ya knight c6 and
for some reason they just allow bishop
c4 one subtlety bishop c4 queen a5 check
do not forget about blocking the check
with tempo that's a very important
concept so what should white do after
bishop c4 queen a5 check how should
white deal with the check
bishop d2 we dropped the bishop back to
d2 with the double attack against the
queen and the pawn
easy
okay
well this has to be a glitch because
it's and i mentioned this in my previous
puzzle solving video sometimes this
happens
where you essentially get a maiden 2 or
a maiden 3
uh you know puzzle 49 and then you saw
the one that i got wrong
i mean not to
you know i i should have gotten it right
but
that was incredibly hard so this is
crazy queen f2 queen f1 is just a back
rank mate this is literally exactly like
the one we solved on puzzle number 10.
in f2 is there any tricks now when you
see a situation like this you just got
to make sure that nothing is pinned that
white doesn't capture something with
check sometimes that happens but that's
odd all right last one
okay
so
here we have a situation where we've got
a rook for two pieces and white's got a
very weak king
and very flimsy
like the first thing i see is that the
bishop on b3 is the type two undefended
piece and the only piece protecting it
is the queen we've had the situation
occur many many times
and
and so consequently
the move that comes to mind and thank
you so much tori for the raid the move
that comes to my mind is is rook dw8
that doubles the rooks and it hits the
the bishop on b3
however
let's not stop there because after rook
v8 there is something that concerns me
and i'm going to ask my chat what it is
white has a very concerning response to
rook db8 again and again
the bishop doesn't have to move white
can block that with knight b5
and if you've been following the
principles you'll notice that the queen
and the king are aligned on the same
file but there is no pin available
because both c8 and c7 are inaccessible
to black's pieces
so
i'm really unconvinced by that
but
now we ask ourselves do we have any
other ways of attacking this bishop
let's try to be more direct what about
rook before
what about rook b4 this hits the queen
and if the queen moves then we just take
the bishop
white could trade on d8 but i don't see
how that changes the
the the landscape of the position i
think we we win the bishop by forcing
the queen out this is a classic
application of
uh classic application of
type 2 undefended pieces queen a6 now do
not take the rook first because then the
bishop takes we don't need to do that we
just take and there's 50. and now before
we wrap up let us take a look at that
puzzle that i got wrong
um now in order to click on it i think i
i have to finish up the run here so i'm
going to get three wrong just on purpose
just so that i can click on that one and
analyze it
so let me just
try to get them wrong oh that was
accidentally correct okay this is not
going to be right
okay now let's see
so my solution was and actually let me
click on the analysis board uh just in
order to
be able to see the uh
see the evol here
okay so my move was knight d6
which indeed leads to a drop bishop
takes wait a minute
we might have an alternate solution
situation here
have i been redeemed let's see bishop
take c1
have i been redeemed
knight f7 king g8 knight ed8 this is
very similar to what i suggested
i agree it's much less clear cut
apparently than what the solution is but
i believe that plus 10 would qualify as
a win yeah these are unstoppable threads
bishop takes f2 now you just need to
evade the checks
and i'm giving the computer some time to
assess this but it does seem to be
winning
it's danny wretch's fault he was just in
the chat
yeah bishop takes c6 rook takes c6 is
totally crushing
okay so
i have been if you've watched all this
way to the end of the video i have been
redeemed but the move is knight g5
why did i reject this i rejected this
because of h6
oh
and here there is this very cool pattern
knight f7 king h7 and i missed the move
knight e7 so my mistake was not to
calculate deeply enough and the point of
this is that the king has no escape
squares
and what's gonna follow is a check on
this diagonal which is going to be
totally devastating so
that was a really nice solution but
i believe that my move
also does
does do the trick so
um so that was really really fun uh let
me just go back to the
the puzzle rush board and that was 50.
that was a long video
um i will definitely do a subsequent
video at some point in the future where
i do puzzles over 50 but i hope that you
were able to see kind of what the
progression looks like and if you're
newer to chess i hope that you were able
to
to
realize that some of these problems in
the 30s and 40s are very much solvable
if you if you follow the right uh the
right process and you make observations
and you're tenacious and very
importantly when you do something like
this go over your mistakes and make sure
that you're kind of making mental note
of patterns whether it's a mating
pattern or a double attack uh try to
make sure that you're you're kind of
trying to figure out um what those
patterns are and really putting it in
your mental library that's the way that
you uh that you progress all right hope
you enjoyed the video
and uh in the next set of videos my
positional and end game series will
continue but hope you had fun thanks for
watching and i'll see you in in the next
video